how to be a successful teenage
entrepreneur so I got a great question
from one of my youtube viewers love you
guys
COC tips and tricks who wrote in to say
please make a video around teenage
startups such as tips and advice thanks
Evan this is a fantastic question and I
know a lot of teenagers are frustrated
with the current job economy you want to
make a difference you want to do your
own thing you want to be independent you
want to make a lot of money and the way
to do that often isn't to go work at a
big business I remember one of my first
summer jobs I was doing data entry
it was super boring work super manual
work basically just taking what I saw on
the page and typing it out into a field
that I would put on a computer
spreadsheet I was put on a team of five
people who are all doing the same thing
the difference with me was I never left
my desk I didn't take lunch breaks I
didn't take smoking breaks I went to the
washroom only when I had to I was
working it out and to help me work I
used to always have food at my desk so I
could eat and headphones so I could
listen to music cuz that's pretty boring
stuff I remember my manager was looking
at me and disapproved of what I was
doing he didn't feel the people should
eat at their desk or listen to music and
he almost fired me and then he looked at
the results and saw that I was getting
more work done than the other four
people on my team combined
so he kept me on but gave me a warning
no more eating at my desk and no more
listening to music
gotta love terrible managers so instead
I kept my food in my top drawer and
snuck bites when he wasn't around and I
put my music player on the floor and ran
a wire up my jeans through a turtleneck
now that I wore everyday and just had
one earbud come out so I could listen to
the music while I was working but that
experience really made me feel like I
got to do something on my own
I had a bunch of failed companies but
the one that really took off was the
biotech software company that I got
involved with when I was 19 years old
and I took it from making three hundred
dollars a month and barely being able to
survive to selling it for seven figures
in three years so here's some advice
that I have for you based on my success
as a teenage entrepreneur number one is
model success there's never been more
role models for young people now to be
successful entrepreneurs research the
stories of people who are making it so
found yourself with excellence and
success from young people who are doing
great things you'll find that they not
only give you ideas and strategies to
help you grow your business but also
keep you motivated and wanting to keep
going I would find one people who are in
your industry who are doing really well
and two people who you look up to and
want to emulate and there are your
business heroes create an environment of
success and surround yourself with role
models of people who you want to be like
number two is get experience this is all
about providing value and a challenge to
a lot of young people is you don't have
enough experience we can provide a lot
of great value so go get some experience
whether it's working for somebody
volunteering at events being mentored by
somebody you want to get experience in
your industry so you can provide more
value to customers to help build my
company up when I was in university I
use my company as school projects for
any time we had any kind of initiative
at school so if it was a marketing class
I'd use my business if it was a pricing
class I'd use my business if it was an
accounting class I'd use my business I
got practical knowledge and could apply
it immediately into my company then when
I sold my business I hooked up with a
venture capital company I felt like I
only understood how my business was run
and I wanted to learn a lot more about
other businesses and also about how
money was being raised that's why it's
so easy for me now to jump into almost
any business and offer practical advice
it's not because I'm some kind of genius
it's because through the venture capital
business I had exposure to thousands of
different companies that then I was able
to help them grow their business I went
out and got experience you want to do
the same with your company so whatever
is you want to learn whatever you feel
is missing whatever feel you need to get
better at go take a course go volunteer
go get a part-time job learn get
experience and get better
number three is take consistent action
you got to do something every day to
move your business idea forward and as a
teenager I get that it can be difficult
at times to find the time to do your
business you've got school and friends
and extracurricular activities there's
lots of demand on your time but you have
to find a way to do something every
single day to move your business forward
you have an exam
tomorrow you're still spending half an
hour today doing something for your
company it has to be that important to
you or it's not going to take off so
model success get experience and take
consistent action and believe thanks for
the great question if you guys watch and
have some extra tips you want to share
leave it in the comments below
and if you want to see more videos just
like this consider subscribing to the
channel thank you so much for watching
I'll see you soon sign up for the
newsletter for more believe
you